[Research on conjoined twins part 1]
[The USSR Academy of Medical Sciences]
[Neural and humoral factors in the regulation of bodily functions (research on conjoined twins)]
[Research director, full member of the USSR Academy of Medical Sciences professor P.K. Anokhin]
[Basic scientific research performed by Candidate of Medical Sciences T.T. Alekseeva]
[Director N.P. Il'zina
Operator N.A. Arkhipov
Animator L.IA. Kal']
[Department of Scientific Film and Photo Documentation
of the USSR Academy of Medical Sciences, 1957]
[The role of neural and humoral factors in the solution
of certain physiological problems remained unknown,
because in the conditions of the experiment each of them was assessed separately.]
[Conjoined twins are being demonstrated.]
[Narrator:] The role of neural and humoral factors in the solution
of certain physiological problems remained unknown,
due to the conditions of the experiment,
where each of them was assessed separately.
[A bath is drawn and water temperature is measured.]
[Narrator:] Due to their unique physiological properties,
conjoined twins are extremely rare objects for solving controversial questions
regarding the regulation of bodily functions of organisms,
in which the interrelationship of neural and humoral mechanisms seemed the most complicated.
[The conjoined twins are given a bath in a small basin.]
[Narrator:] Scarce descriptions of conjoined twins in the world literature address primarily
their external appearance and anatomical structure,
since most of them were stillborn.
[The conjoined twins are towel-dried and swaddled.]
[A nurse holds the babies in her arms, looks down at them and smiles.]
[The conjoined twins are lying in bed, facing each other.]
[The X-ray photograph of the conjoined twins in supine position is shown.]
[Narrator:] In 1937, in one of the maternity hospitals of the Soviet Union,
the conjoined twins Ira-Galia were born.
The twins survived one year and twenty-two days.
The anatomical and physiological features of the twins
were studied while they were still alive.
[Close-up X-ray photo of the conjoined twins' pelvis area is shown.]
[Narrator:] The X-ray photograph shows two spines.
[Back to the original X-ray supine position photo of the conjoined twins.]
[X-ray photo changes to image of twins in prone position.]
[Narrator:] The coccyx sections of the spines were fused together;
however, the spinal canals remained isolated.
[X-ray photo of the conjoined twins with the highlighted spinal cords
and peripheral nervous system is shown.]
[Narrator:] Respectively, the structures of the vertebral canals
of the twins' neural system were entirely separated from each other.
[Close-up X-ray photo of the spinal nerves.]
[Narrator:] At the point of fusion, the nerve roots of the inner sides of the spine
are joined into a rudimental tail.
These nerves, lacking an innervation zone due to the absence of the two extremities,
are significantly thinner than the nerves of the outer side of the spine.
[X-ray photo demonstrates a vertebra where the nerves are very thin,
then changes back to a close-up of the X-ray photo of the spinal nerves.]
[Narrator:] Microscopic studies conducted by Rampan showed that
the segments of the cervical and thoracic sections have a normal structure.
[X-ray photo demonstrates normally developed vertebrae.]
[Narrator:] Inside the lumbar section of the spinal cord,
the grey matter of the anterior horns,
corresponding to the absent extremities, is stunted.
[The conjoined twins are shown in bed in supine position.]
[X-ray photograph of the twins' upper body is shown.]
[Narrator:] The number of ganglion cells in these areas of the spinal cord is limited.
[The conjoined twins are shown in bed in supine position.]
[Narrator:] In contrast to the nervous system, the twins' blood circulation was common.
The blood of one child could freely flow to the other,
as was apparent from the venous net, visible through the abdominal skin.
[X-ray photo of the conjoined twins with highlighted circulatory system.]
[Narrator:] The common bloodstream, besides the sub-dermic venous system,
can be seen as well in the system of abdominal aortas,
where the direct arterial anastomoses were located.
[A picture of the conjoined twins' abdominal vascular system is shown.]
[Narrator:] The post-mortem, performed by professor Shangina,
demonstrated a close vascular connection in almost of all the internal organs' blood vessels.
[Swaddled newborn conjoined twins are shown sleeping, then uncovered and awake, then crying.]
[Narrator:] For example, the veins of both intestinal systems join together
and the mixed blood flows to the liver through the separate portal veins.
[Narrator:] In 1950 another pair of conjoined twins was born, Masha-Dasha.
[Newborn naked conjoined twins are shown.]
[Then the X-ray photograph of the conjoined twins is displayed,
followed by a close-up of the third hip joint.]
[Narrator:] They had two torsos, four arms.
The twins had two regular legs and a third one,
made out of two legs fused together.
An X-ray also demonstrated that these girls had two completely separate spines,
down to the coccyx bones.
[A picture of the conjoined twins' highlighted nervous systems is shown.]
[Narrator:] Their spinal canals are separate as well.
The nervous system of these twins was also divided
according to the location of the spinal canals.
The innervation of the arms and the regular legs
corresponded to the usual anatomically normal ratios.
The innervation of the fused leg is divided.
Its nerves proceed from the spinal cord of each girl.
[Newborn naked sleeping conjoined twins are shown.]
[Narrator:] The blood circulation of the second twin pair Masha-Dasha,
similarly to the blood circulation of Ira-Galia, was common.
Anastomosis of the venous net is also visible through the abdominal skin.
[Glucose loading table is drawn, using multiplication technique.]
[Narrator:] The rapidity of blood transfer from one child to the other
was calculated with the help of a glucose-loading experiment,
which was conducted in both pairs of twins.
The amount of sugar before loading is estimated.
100 ml of glucose is injected into Ira's scalp vein.
In less than two minutes after the injection,
the blood glucose count is high in both of the girls.
Similar results were obtained during the glucose loading in the Masha-Dasha twins.
[Table of thyroid assimilation of iodine is drawn, using multiplication technique.]
[Narrator:] Additional radioactive iodine experiments were conducted on Masha-Dasha.
After Masha had taken radioactive iodine orally,
the iodine absorption by the thyroid glands in both girls occurred in 10 minutes.
The above indicates close humoral interaction between both twin organisms,
and that practically all substances are equally distributed in a common blood flow.
[The newborn conjoined twins are lying in bed, naked.]
[A nurse repeatedly pricks the twins, checking their reaction.]
[Narrator:] Receptor zone boundaries
and the degree of their isolation were studied in both pairs of twins.
Light irritation in the innervation area, located 1 cm from the navel in Ira's direction,
causes a reaction only from Ira.
The same irritation, located 1 cm from the navel in Galia's direction,
causes a reaction only from Galia.
The above indicates that the median line of the skin is the accurate border
of innervation by dorsal root filaments from both spinal cords.
[The nurse gives the conjoined twins an injection,
first in one leg, then in the other leg.]
[First one twin, then the second twin cries.]
[Narrator:] Injections of pharmaceutical preparations were conducted for therapeutic purposes.
Only the girl who was receiving the injection in her leg reacted by crying.
The other girl remained calm.
[Narrator:] The above observation is not consistent
with the theory of the humoral nature of pain factors.
[View of the twins from above.]
[Narrator:] In addition to the separate sensitivity zones,
extensor muscle apparatuses were divided as well.
Each girl could arbitrarily manipulate only one leg--her own.
[Newborn Masha-Dasha twins are lying in bed, naked.]
[A nurse pricks first one twin, then the second one, checking their reaction.]
[Narrator:] The second pair of twins also displayed full isolation of receptor zones.
During the light irritation in the navel area in Masha's direction, only Masha was crying.
The skin irritation near the navel in Dasha's direction resulted in crying only from Dasha.
[Nurse alternately applies pressure to the bottom of each foot.]
[First only Dasha, then only Masha is crying.]
[Narrator:] The legs, in exactly the same way, belonged one to Dasha, the other to Masha.
[Close-up of crying Masha.]
[Narrator:] The nerves in the third leg ran side by side without anastomosing.
The observations of both pairs of twins have allowed us
to establish a significant similarity in their physiological functions.
The full isolation of the nervous apparatus
and the commonality of humoral connections determined all the differences
in the behavior and body reactions of the twins.
[The twins are active, then one girl is asleep while the other is playing with a rattle.]
[Narrator:] The tests, conducted in exactly the same conditions of the environment
and the same routine, demonstrated that the twins' development rates were
unequal when it came to their behavior,
static and motor skills development,
and to the acquisition of conditioned responses.
Ira and Galia differed little from each other in their physical condition,
but Ira surpassed Galia in her mental development.
She was the first to learn to sit up, and she was the first to smile as well.
[One of the twins reaches for the nurse's hands, smiles.]
[Narrator:] Individual differences are also evident in Masha's and Dasha's behavior.
[Twins are swaddled, nurse is shaking a rattle over one of the girls.]
[Narrator:] In the first months of their lives this difference was minimally expressed.
At the age of three months both girls weren't able to hold their heads.
Still, object fixation in that age is better expressed in Masha.
She independently captures a toy.
[The twins, a little older, both in patterned dresses and white bibs, are active.]
[A large rattle is hanging over the cradle.]
[Masha is holding a toy parrot in her hand and is vigorously waving it around.]
[A nurse shows a knitted sock to Masha, who first tries to reach it, than gives up.]
[A nurse puts a sock on her foot.]
[When the nurse moves to put the other sock on Dasha's foot, she actively interacts with her.]
[Narrator:] However, later, due to her tendency to get tired easily,
Masha began to fall behind Dasha in her development.
At the age of 18 months Dasha accurately performed elementary tasks,
willingly raised her leg up when the sock was pulled on.
Masha wouldn't perform as requested; she was distracted by the surrounding scene.
[One of the twins is shown playing with her leg, while a nurse is talking to her.]
[Narrator:] Dasha also moved the joint leg more, and, when asked, raised it up.
[Nurse is giving spoons to the twins, Dasha takes a spoon and starts playing.]
[Masha reacts more slowly, doesn't play, and is visibly distracted by the camera.]
[Narrator:] The children's tasks became more complicated with age.
The twins' attitude to various items was becoming apparent.
Masha was able to part with the toys and other things without a protest.
In response to a request she at once surrenders a spoon
and quickly switches her attention to other items.
[Dasha is very protective of her spoon.]
[She clutches it, screams, tries to get it back, and succeeds.]
[Narrator:] Dasha has a pronounced active-defensive reaction.
She doesn't comply with the request, and keeps the spoon.
[Nurse gives each of the girls a cookie, than takes it away from Masha, who actively resists.]
[Narrator:] The same reaction appears in Masha when she is given sweets.
She is very fond of cookies and reluctant to part with them.
[Dasha pulls a sock on her leg. Masha is very reluctant to even take a sock into her hands.]
[Finally she takes it, starts pulling it on, but gets distracted and throws it away.]
[Narrator:] At the age of two Dasha acquired her initial labor skills;
she independently started to pull a stocking on her leg.
It's difficult to persuade Masha to even take a stocking in her hand.
She unsuccessfully attempts to pull a stocking on, then gets rid of it.
[A nurse attempts to give a wrapped candy to Masha, but she doesn't take it.
At the same time Dasha takes her candy, unwraps both layers,
hands the wrappers back to the nurse, and puts the candy in her mouth.
When Masha finally takes her wrapped candy, she isn't sure what to do with it.]
[Narrator:] At a more advanced age,
Dasha performed differentiated movements with the utmost precision.
She unwraps a candy quickly and skillfully.
Masha doesn't even make an attempt to unwrap her candy.
[The twins are playing with blocks. Dasha builds a tower.]
[Masha prefers to scatter the blocks instead of building a structure herself.]
[Narrator:] Dasha quickly puts the building blocks together.
Masha would rather destroy the constructions
instead of attempting to build anything herself.
[The twins are shown in an open crib.]
[A nurse comes, greets them with a handshake,
and hands a rubber hose ending in a small balloon to each of them.]
[Narrator:] Differences in neuro-psychological reactions were confirmed in laboratory conditions.
Motor-conditioned responses are developed.
The research was conducted by Alekseeva, Kriuchkova, and Ostrovskaia.
In response to the word 'press' the children must press the rubber balloon with their hand.
The word 'press' is preceded by conditioning signals, a ring, and a light.
[A nurse is sitting at a desk adjacent to the crib.]
[She is conducting the experiment by moving levers on a control panel.]
[Narrator:] It is presumed that the conditioned response is developed
when the girls press the balloon directly after the ring or light signal.
The bell rings.
[A bell is ringing.]
[Narrator:] Dasha is the first to press the balloon. The top second curve marks Masha's movements.
[A close-up of an apparatus recording the twins' conditioned movement reflexes on paper is shown,
then the picture switches back to the nurse at the desk.]
[Narrator:] Signal light.The first to respond to the stimulus is Dasha (top recording)
[Masha is tired. She throws the ball away. The nurse pulls a lever again.]
[A bell is ringing. Masha has both balloons in her hands.]
[Dasha takes her balloon and presses it. She is the first again.]
[Narrator:] Signal again. Again, Dasha is the first to press [the balloon].
Masha is tired, she discards the balloon and doesn't want to continue.
At this point the task diversifies.
Both balloons are in Masha's hands.
Signal sounds. Dasha snatches her balloon, presses.
Therefore, Dasha developed the conditioned response faster.
[The twins play with rubber balls.]
[Narrator:] Comparing the children's behavior with the conditioned responses,
one can conclude that the twins noticeably differed in their higher nervous activity,
i.e., each one had her own typological features.
[Differentiation of nervous systems and the commonality of blood circulation
in twins presented an opportunity to reveal the role of
nervous and humoral factors in the occurrence of sleep.]
[Newborn conjoined twins are shown, first active, then both asleep.]
[Narrator:] Differentiation of nervous systems and the commonality of blood circulation
in twins presented an opportunity to discover
the role of nervous and humoral factors in the occurrence of sleep.
Most of the time, the girls' sleep was simultaneous.
However, they were able to sleep independently,
and such opposite physiological states "the sleep of one and the wakefulness of the other"
could continue for a lengthy period of time, up to two hours and more.
[One twin is shown awake, while the other is asleep.]
[Narrator:] The states of sleep and wakefulness in the first pair of twins, Ira-Galia,
also were occurring both simultaneously and separately.
Ira is asleep, Galia is awake.
Galia is asleep, Ira is awake.
Galia is laughing, Ira is asleep.
[Pneumograms of sleep/wake patterns of both pairs of conjoined twins are presented.]
[Narrator:] All the autonomic nervous system indicators
during sleep and wakefulness changed in accordance with the condition of each child.
During simultaneous sleep, the twins' breathing was synchronized.
During individual sleep, the pneumogram's recording changed respectively,
the breathing of the wakeful child was always more energetic,
i.e., deeper and more frequent.
The heartbeat of the wakeful child was faster,
the individual spikes of the electrocardiogram higher in comparison to the sleeping child.
[The twins, one asleep, one awake, are shown.]
[Narrator:] With age, the children's sleep and wakefulness
continued to be independent states for each child.
[The conjoined twins Masha and Dasha are shown sleeping.]
[Narrator:] The girls turned five.
Due to the same schedule, most of the time the children slept simultaneously.
In these cases, sleep occurred as a result of the conditioned responses.
When one of the children calmed down, it worked as a conditioning signal to the other child,
and she would fall asleep as well.
[Masha is shown playing, while Dasha is asleep.]
[Narrator:] The simultaneous existence of both states 'sleep and wakefulness'
in conjunction with common blood circulation and separate nervous systems
is direct proof of the crucial role of the nervous system in sleep occurrence,
which speaks against the humoral theory of sleep.
[End of part 1.]
[Research on conjoined twins part 2]
[The role of neural and humoral factors in alimentary stimulation.]
[The X-ray photograph of the conjoined twins in supine position is shown.]
[Narrator:] The role of neural and humoral factors in alimentary stimulation.
The existence of separate stomachs in the twins created the conditions
for the normal nutrition of each child.
Gastric digestion was occurring separately, the same as in the duodenum.
However, absorbing digestive juices were entering the common bloodstream.
[The conjoined twins are shown in a crib, swaddled. A nurse bottle-feeds them.]
[Narrator:] Based on these anatomical and physiological peculiarities,
observations of alimentary stimulation in twins were conducted.
During the first six months of life, the children received food every two to three hours.
They were always fed at the same time and were given equal portions.
Each girl was drinking up to 75 ml of milk in one feeding.
[One of the conjoined twins, approximately six months old,is spoon-fed, while the other twin is crying.]
[Narrator:] Study of alimentary stimulation was conducted
by means of separate feeding of one of the twins.
The blood sugar and the gastric juice composition
of the child not receiving food were measured.
The study consisted of one child being fed, while the other was not.
[An attempt to distract the crying twin with a rattle.]
[Table labeled 'Amount of food ingested during separate feedings' is drawn,
first for Ira-Galia, then for Masha-Dasha.]
[Narrator:] The same studies were conducted also on the first pair of twins, Ira-Galia.
The amount of milk consumed by each of the girls in one feeding is recorded.
Next time Galia was not given milk (it is shown as a dash on the diagram).
After two skipped feedings it was found out that Galia was drinking a larger amount of milk.
Similar results were received also from the Masha-Dasha twins.
After two skipped feedings Dasha was drinking considerably more milk
than her usual portion during the regular feedings.
[Dasha is being spoon-fed. She is eating vigorously.]
[After that both twins look very content.]
[The conjoined twins are lying in a crib, dressed in small print dresses.]
[A nurse ties a bib around the twin on the left.]
[Narrator:] During the first year of life, pronounced alimentary stimulation
was observed both during separate and simultaneous feedings.
Alimentary stimulation of the child not receiving food is increased
by such conditioned response stimuli as preparation for
food intake and the feeding of the other child.
[The twin on the left is spoon-fed.]
[After the feeding, the nurse takes the soiled bib off the child
and ties a clean bib around the other twin.]
[It is Dasha's turn to be fed.]
[The twins are in a crib. They are older, perhaps three or four years old.]
[A nurse comes with two plates of food and gives a plate to each of the girls.]
[The girls are eating independently.]
[Narrator:] The children's behavior during food intake changes only
with the development of speech communication.
[Each twin has a tube inserted into her mouth, apparently running to her stomach.]
[Narrator:] Gastric juice studies were conducted in order to prove
that the products of digested nutrients indeed entered the common bloodstream.
[A comparative table of gastric juice analysis for Masha and Dasha is drawn.]
[Gastric juice, free acid, common acidity.]
[Narrator:] The chemical composition of gastric juice
taken from Masha and Dasha after fasting was studied.
Both gastric juice composition and its strength were the same in both girls.
[Dasha is spoon-fed, while Masha has a tube inserted for gastric juice analysis.]
[Narrator:] While one of the girls was being fed, there were observed two-phased changes
in the quantity and the acidity of the hungry child's gastric juice.
[A table 'Gastric juice analysis of Masha (Dasha's being fed)' is drawn.]
[Narrator:] The first increase coincides with the neuro-psychiatric phase,
while the second with the neuro-chemical phase.
[A screen is placed between the girls.]
[The experiment in which Dasha is being fed
and Masha's gastric juice is being measured and analyzed, is repeated.]
[Narrator:] Throughout the course of separate feeding of one girl,
the quantity and the acidity of the gastric juice of the child not being fed
also increases, during both the 'nervous' and the 'chemical' phases.
The studies of alimentary stimulation conducted by feeding one of the children separately,
together with the simultaneous gastric juice analysis of the fasting child,
demonstrate that the alimentary stimulation of one child does not decrease when the other one is fed.
[The twins are shown in a dining room, sitting at a round table
covered with a white tablecloth, eating and smiling.]
[Narrator:] These observations indicate the leading role of the tongue and digestive tract receptors
in the regulation of food center activity; in other words, the states of appetite and satiation.
[The twins continue eating and drinking.]
[Comparative traits of the twins' pathological conditions.]
[Narrator:] Comparative traits of the twins' pathological conditions.
[The twins are lying in bed, covered with a sheet.]
[A nurse inserts a thermometer under an arm of each girl.]
[Narrator:] The conducted observational studies of the pathological reactions
of the twins revealed the significance of the nervous or humoral factors
in the processes of the human body's thermoregulation.
The role of blood temperature in thermoregulation can be determined
only by research on conjoined twins, who share a single bloodstream
to such a degree that the physicochemical changes in blood
over a short period of time 'one to two minutes' are discovered simultaneously in both girls.
[Close-up of each girl. The nurse returns and removes the thermometers.]
[Narrator:] In the usual, normal conditions, the body temperature of the twins,
both in the armpit and the symmetrical skin folds, is within the range of physiological fluctuations.
For example, Dasha's [temperature] is 36.7 [C], Masha's 36.6 [C].
[A table 'Body temperature during a disease' is drawn.]
[Narrator:] Throughout the first year of the children's lives,
the body temperature of simultaneously sick girls increased simultaneously.
[Another temperature table is drawn 'Age 3 months. Masha is sick, Dasha is healthy'.]
[Narrator:] Synchronicity of body temperature was observed also during the individual diseases of the twins.
At the age of three months, Masha was diagnosed with acute otitis media of the right ear.
Dasha was healthy; however, the temperature rose in both girls and stayed elevated for eight days.
[A temperature table 'Age 2 years 2 months. Masha is sick, Dasha is healthy' is drawn.]
[Narrator:] With age, the character of temperature reaction during the pathological conditions changes.
At times of individual diseases, the body temperatures do not match.
At the age of two Masha gets sick.
Her temperature rises to 39 degrees [C], while Dasha's [temperature] does not exceed 37.2 [C].
[Next temperature table 'Age 3 years. Masha is sick' is drawn.]
[Narrator:] At the age of three, Masha fell ill with left-sided pneumonia.
Dasha had no symptoms of the disease.
Masha's temperature rose to 39 degrees [C], while Dasha's temperature did not rise above 37 degrees [C].
[A hospital bed with Masha and Dasha is shown.]
[Anurse is measuring skin surface temperature with a special apparatus.]
[Narrator:] The skin temperatures also were measured simultaneously
in both girls as in normal conditions, as during a disease.
The skin temperatures corresponded to the readings of body temperatures.
This indicates that the mechanisms of thermoregulation
are perfected with the children's age,
and that the blood temperature does not have crucial
significance for the determination of body temperature level.
[Observations conducted on the conjoined twins lead to the conclusion
that the processes of sleep, disease, hunger, and satiation develop
under the dominating influence of the nervous system.]
[Narrator:] Observations conducted on the conjoined twins
lead us to the conclusion that the processes of sleep, disease, hunger, and satiation develop
under the dominating influence of the nervous system.
[The twins, a few months old, are shown being pulled by their hands
to a sitting position, first one, then the other.]
[Narrator:] It has become apparent at an early age that Dasha's and Masha's
development of motor activity had individual differences.
Masha was the first to learn how to hold her head up,
while Dasha was not able to hold her head steady.
[The nurse is talking to Dasha, who is actively responding by moving her arms and legs,
and moving her entire body from side to side in a rocking motion. Masha is rather passive.]
[Narrator:] General physical activity, like a rocking movement of the trunk,
was more pronounced in Dasha.
Dasha was the first to sit up without assistance.
At that time Masha did not even attempt to sit up.
[The twins are in a large playpen. Masha is lying on her back; Dasha is sitting.]
[Narrator:] When the children began to crawl,
it was Dasha who always initiated the movement in the playpen.
[The twins are crawling inside the playpen; Dasha is leading.]
[The twins, looking a bit older, move around the playpen in coordinated motion.]
[Narrator:] The movement coordination started to appear at the age of two and a half.
[The twins, visibly older, are lying on a bed,
then in perfectly coordinated motion sit up, stand up, look out of the window,
smile and wave, and lower themselves back on the bed.]
[Narrator:] By the age of five, the girls begin to get out of bed without any assistance,
and are able to remain in a vertical position for an extended period of time.
[A nurse helps the girls to walk on the grass.]
[Narrator:] The first attempts at movement were unsuccessful.
The segregated innervation of the legs could not provide a coordinated correlation between them.
[The twins are in the exercise room.]
[Each of the girls is holding a crutch, and they are successfully moving sideways.]
[They hold their balance very well. ]
[While the twins are leaning on a Swedish wall bar, Dasha lifts her leg and ties her shoe.]
[Masha, in her turn, also demonstrates her balance and shoe-tying skill.]
[Narrator:] The development of a walking function is of great scientific interest,
since it must be implemented by two separate bodies,
where each of them is able to use only one leg for the above function.
[The twins are lying on a mat, lifting their arms and legs in synchronized movements.]
[The exercise is designed to help increase their movement coordination and help with motion.]
[Narrator:] In order to teach the twins the walking function,
which for them is complicated,
and to develop a coordinated movement of the limbs
similar to the reciprocal coordination of a regular person,
the Central Institute of Prosthetics and Prosthesis Construction
has conducted difficult and persistent work,
advancing their motor skills.
[The twins are riding a tricycle.]
[Narrator:] Tricycle-riding, which requires synchronized pedal pushing,
was instrumental to the development of movement coordination
between the two isolated nervous systems.
[The twins are at the Swedish wall, holding crutches.]
[They put the crutches aside and climb the wall.]
[At the top the girls turn around, smile, then climb down,
where they retrieve their crutches and start walking forward.]
[Narrator:] The Swedish wall bar exercises
also helped the children to synchronize their movements.
[The girls on crutches walk forward with apparent ease.]
[They stop and stand still, first on crutches, then without any support.]
[Narrator:] During the walk the children effortlessly coordinate their movements.
They are able to walk with their eyes closed, and stand on the crutches
without supporting each other with their free hands.
They can even stand without crutches, while locking their knee joints with their arms.
[The twins on crutches are standing on a stairway landing,
with a nurse behind them holding their hands.]
[With the help of the nurse the girls start walking down the stairs.]
[Narrator:] By then they learned to walk up and down the stairs,
though still with outside assistance.
[The twins are sitting at the desk in a classroom.]
[A nurse shows them illustrations; the girls open their books and read.]
[Later the girls are shown counting pencils, coloring pictures in books, and embroidering.]
[Narrator:] Side by side with gymnastics, the girls are engaged in schoolwork.
The children's psychological development progresses normally and is consistent with their age.
They are learning how to read, to count, to color within the lines, and to embroider well.
And all of their craftwork is skillfully and neatly executed.
[The twins are sitting at a large round table in the dining room,
accompanied by other children and adults.]
[This is a celebration of the twins' seventh birthday. ]
[A cake with the words 'Masha and Dasha are 7' is on the table in front of the girls.]
[They all drink tea, eat fruit and pastries, and look very happy.]
[Narrator:] In December 1957 Masha and Dasha turned seven.
Not only the children's peers came to wish them a happy birthday, but their adult friends as well,
the entire numerous and friendly staff of medical workers and researchers.
[Two distinguished older men join the table, eat and talk to the twins.]
[They are professors who work with the twins.]
[Narrator:] Professor Anokhin and Professor Popov also came
to congratulate Masha and Dasha on their birthday.
[The twins come to a coffee table with the gifts, look at them, and play with the toys.]
[At the end they look up, smile and wave.]
[Narrator:] Further development of the twins, mental as well as physical, will continue,
without a doubt, to progress under the influence of both humoral and neural factors.
The former is stable, but the latter, in accordance with Masha's and Dasha's age,
undergoes obvious differentiation.
Thus, it opens the promising prospects in future studies
for the assessment of neural and humoral factors in the mental life of the twins.
The end.